[Musique]
pour le baron ayant nounours ils ne sont
pas encore cuites et marron et puis ce
ne sont pas des marrons mais des
châtaignes
c'est vrai patron je descends de ce pain
les faire griller chez mes petits amis
ont les cheveux tombent ou le marron ou
le marron et or ont ils été rayé de sa
nounou russe
il m'a fait oublier de vous dire bonsoir
bonsoir les enfants
[Musique]
minois ne s'est pas débarrassé du châtel
qu'on veut voir maman sont plutôt froide
et châtaignes nous allons les faire
briller
elles seront croustillantes et bien paul
labranche
la visite commence a conclu neuchâtel
j'allais voir vous allez voir non mon
nouveau le four on verse chatr dedans et
on attend sa zone c'est vrai que je suis
bête à il est électrique
les parfums les enfants nicolas demorand
bois le monde voilà monsieur la cuisine
merci mon plus attention à tout oulala
je brûle et où le lot on peut tous nos
voeux petit pas tout
tu veux dire la grosse tête
vauban petit pot tout je veux bonbons
que tu es maladroit 90e nous sommes
accompagnés dans une tabelle pas tout
[Musique]
l'écurie ne pleure plus merci où elle
brûle [ __ ]
il faut les sortir du four sur teulet
vous moi je suis un pauvre non qu'elles
sont mal ce j'adhère rôle son viatique
août on voit quelle horreur le tout
bruit la mienne est délicieux la mienne
aussi
et celle là elle est aussi brûlé lieu
toutes les mauvaises mois toutes les
mauvaises maintenant on a bien mangé oui
maintenant face cachée petit corps ne
vous avez mangé toutes les bottes
et moi moi j'aime alabak people
où
[Musique]
no push to talk to me faire un gros
budget là ça va mieux
oui je me sens dormi j'éteins la lumière
le
[Musique]
bonne nuit et colas en hip hop rebelles
on
[Musique]
te voilà gros maladroit je n'ai rien
patron plus de gens plus molle et bien
vous voyez mes petits amis
il ne faut jamais joué avec le feu sinon
vous brûlerez les mains comme nounours
suffit nu patron tu fus d'une à lévis
dodo les petits et fait des rêves d'or
bonne nuit à demain paul venu à deux
hommes
[Musique]